tu vas voir ce qui se passe quand c'est
une panne l'émetteur aujourd'hui le
téléspectateur est un client exigeant
pour le satisfaire les professionnels de
la télévision le sonde régulièrement
pour lui offrir des programmes de plus
en plus captivant mais hélas il arrive
parfois que la 10 des coûts de certaines
émissions pourtant de grande qualité se
trouve bouleversée par
d'incompréhensible caprices et redire
quand ya une panne la première réaction
c'est de zapper pour vinci des
concurrents eux aussi profitent ou
bénéficier de cette panne
nous avons eu en 1990 11960 coupure
d'émetteurs de télévision
alors il faut pondérer chiffre par deux
considérations premièrement beaucoup de
ces coupures sont courtes de courte
durée deuxièmement nous avons plusieurs
milliers d'installations pour desservir
l'ensemble du territoire comme nous
avons vous et moi ne tous le même
diffuseur généralement lorsqu à une
panne des moteurs
elle profite à tout le monde mais qu'en
est-il de l'audimat quand une sournoise
pas d'émetteurs prive cruellement les
téléspectateurs de leur émission
préférée une récente étude nous apprend
qu'il ne quitte pas pour autant leur
téléviseur premier enseignement c'est
surprenant c'est la pourcentage de
récepteurs qui restent allumées en cas
de panne et qui s'élève à plus d'un
tiers des récepteurs 36% au total de la
population dont 15% pour tf1 8 ou 9%
pour un thème 2 4% sur fr3 et le total
c'est-à-dire notre 10 points qui reste
se partage entre les autres chaînes mais
je ne connaissais pas ce sondage ce que
je sais c'est qu'aux états unis on a
mesuré
debbie des chasses d'eau en cas de
rupture d'écran le nombre d'enfants fait
dans les ascenseurs mais ça me semble
tout à fait intéressant comme question
c'est vrai qu'on a une qualité de passe
exceptionnelle et que la neige
s'ils voulaient qu'ils tombent devant
l'écran est meilleure que la vôtre ça ça
j'y peux rien il arrive même parfois si
vous voulez que dans certains programmes
la panne fasse une meilleure audience
que le programme du fn en tête même
pendant les pannes d'émetteurs s de
l'intox
jean marie bigard à l'oreille stéphanie
à toi de jouer
est-ce de l'info est de l'intox c'est de
l'info c'est de l'info pourquoi je sais
pas tu sais pas mais tu te sens comme ça
après 128 6 ans féminines peut-être et
toi abrégé moi je dirais comme les
autres c'est de la fausse je suis dit
que celles imposées
tu sais pas pourquoi non plus ils ont
tenu bon toi jean marie tu m'as dit que
c'était de la paix est allé parce que
moi je vais il ya un sondage aussi qui
dessert et qu' il ya des fois canal+
kiffan audimat terrible même chez des
gens compote décodeur surtout pendant
les films de cul parce qu'ils les
regardent crypter les films
on voit que c'est plus sexy comme ça bah
oui parce que les dialogues sont souvent
tellement tarte que des fois c'est
presque mieux comme ça va on va écouter
philippe guérin notre expert ah j'avais
peur que ma fille et bavay auprès de
steve de mosnac mais ce n'est pas le cas
c'est de l'intox
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu